in the heart of the Lake District this
hotel and wedding venue has been closed
for weeks it's frightening especially
for Christina cuca who's from Romania if
she lost her job she would also lose her
home we are living stuff and we didn't
know we have to stay we have to leave
what we'll do we'll keep our jobs or not
obviously you concern about money what
will happen you'll be paid or not I was
very scared and nervous I didn't know
what will happen with us the hospitality
sector here relies on overseas workers
but because accommodation is expensive
many live in Craig Hamilton is a bar
manager from South Africa he lost his
job last month and with it the family
home there was no leeway know sort of
grace or anything like that and I even
asked if I could stay in the house and
still pay rent
luckily the supermarkets are looking so
I quickly got a job there and Craig
actually got a job there as well and
starts on Wednesday but even the money
we're gonna be bringing in there's
nowhere near what we were so it's just
kind of everyone's just sort of been
patients and given us a break on payment
holes but we're not looking forward to
it or crumbling back on us three months
from now and we've got to catch up on
all those payments new research shows up
to one in three jobs in the Lake
District could be lost but some
businesses are doing all they can to
keep living staff on and employ new ones
the reason we want to hold on to them
Park this is the right thing to do but
also when we do reopen we will need them
I am worried I'm worried for my seventy
staff I'm worried for my business I'm
worried from a livelihood and I'm
worried really for 55 I worked hard on
my life and to get to wear a mask and
I'm frightened a little business owners
here told us it's strangely enough when
things reopen where they'll see real
problems when they have to pay staff
rent and bills
in full with little or no recent profits
to help Katarina patate see Sky News in
the late